but then in March last year the school
had a swim
the kids were gonna swim into the pool
and I promised I was going to watch it
but I got
I was late coming out of work and I was
only gonna be there in time to meet her
after but when I got there there was an
ambulance and I thought you liked his
pool is in the central media clinic so I
thought it was somebody been dropped
there I didn't really pay any attention
but when I got in there was no one in
the pool and one after teachers was
there with a group of kids and she was
crying and some of the children were
crying and this woman had another one
the moms came over and said that there
had been an accident and miav had his
her head of the pool and cheeping at war
sure they've been trying to resuscitate
her but she said she was going to be all
right and I didn't believe this was
happening you know I thought must be
someone else and I went into I was
brought into a room and Nev was there on
a table it was a table for table tennis
and the ambulance man was giving her the
kiss of life she was into her bathing
suit and the ambulance man said he
didn't think what he was doing was
working he didn't know she was alive so
they wrapped her a towel carried her to
the back of the ambulance and I got in
the back with them and they radioed on
ahead they were going to try put her on
machine in Beaumont try resuscitate her
there but the ambulance man you I think
she wasn't breathing and he just knew
and he said if I wanted to take a bite
her in the ambulance case it didn't get
jobs in the hospital so I gave her a hug
she was freezing cold and I told her
mommy loved her very much
she just she just looked asleep but it
was a gobbler and she was dead
and it's so fast just a few minutes